support as you may expect as poured in
from all around the country but this
tight-knit community of barren Wisconsin
is banding together to welcome Jamie
back this morning everywhere you go on
the street signs and billboards on
churches and banks across the town say
welcome home Jamie praise God we spoke
to several people here to get their
reaction to her surprising and we have
to say improbable return and find out
how the community rallied when she
disappeared why did you just meet in the
search box just felt like I had to do
something to try to help it was so
tragic inside it's just it's a small
community and most people know each
other and we've only lived here about
two years but we're part of the
community now and it was just
heartbreaking did you think it would
turn out this way Lisa you know I didn't
know I hoped we hoped we prayed for
Jamie and we hoped but how did you know
how do you know there's so many and it
was so bizarre and it was it was so
scary and it's very scary forbearing
what are you thinking what do you have
to say well being born and raised in the
area it was pretty scary you know things
like that don't happen around here
I think well that everybody came
together nationwide everywhere you know
I'm even you you know yeah it was scary
it could be anybody's child anybody's
parents I mean it was really scary I am
so thankful she's on my whole family
started crying it was like the best news
ever a lot of people started crying in
you're right Debra best news ever and we
kept hearing things like that don't
happen here well our society has changed
and our next half hour three friends of
Jamie's family talk with us about
banding together and using social media
to encourage the search to keep her in
the public eye these three ladies never
ever gave up right now let's send it
back to New York in the studio they
never gave up Gail and that the town
never gave up either people coming
together and search for Jamie and
obviously we got such great news with
her return Jamie Klaus has an you know
bianna yeah could I just say this one of
the best things I heard was from the
driver Dave who's been driving us around
dave has been great and I said did you
think it would turn out this way he said
well in my brain no but in my heart yes
and I'd like to think the heart always
wins the heart always wins and
everyone's hearts beating a bit harder
and faster today with news that Jamie is
home Gail thank you